but I have to ask is Quentin Tarantino
mad at you because he beats The Living
Daylights out of your character
throughout the from the first minute of
the movie to the last minute of the
movie what's going on there it's brutal
I don't know I there are certain days on
set as I look at myself covered in blood
and bruised and exhausted and just go
this is what
right just because because this guy is
there's something he's acting something
out here or he's killing me yeah yeah
he's killing me but you know he also
created like the best role I've ever had
I mean with things that no one in the
world I mean Kung Fu me I mean you know
that no one would really think of this
combination not that they really should
continue to right but um no but you see
it and you pull it off and I'm watching
this movie and I'm thinking you could be
a Bond girl or you could be James Bond